The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today we are going
to continue discussion about two
very important issues.
The first one is
the understanding
of so-called quarter wave plate.
That may not mean anything
to you in the beginning,
but I hope after
this lecture, you
will know what does that
mean and why that is actually
interesting.
The second thing is that--
the second topic we want to
talk about in the lecture today
is, OK, we have been talking
about electromagnetic waves
for a long time already,
since the last few lectures.
But we have never
touched the topic,
how do we actually create
electromagnetic wave, right?
And we are going to answer
that in the lecture today.
So that's my plan
about these two topics.
OK, so before we
start, it's a reminder
about why we have
learned last time.
So we have learned
several situations
related to polarization.
So we have learned
linearly polarized wave.
What is linearly polarized wave?
If you plot the wave amplitude
as a function of time
as a function of space, it's
going up and down, up and down,
up and down.
And the direction
of the field doesn't
change as a function of time.
So that is actually called
linearly polarized light.
And we also learned circularly
polarized light, right?
When you have two components,
one is in the x direction,
the other one is in the
y direction, if the two
components are out of
phase, say, they differ
by 90 degrees, for example,
and they the same amplitude,
then the superposition
of these two waves
will be a circularly
polarized wave.
So basically, the wave
propagation looks like this.
So basically, the pointy
angle of the electric field
is rotating as a
function over time
as a function of the
distance it travels.
And the other case, which
is also interesting,
is that when you have--
OK, for example, different
phase difference.
Like delta phi different
from 90 degree, or say
you have different amplitude,
although the phase difference
is 90 degree but you
have different amplitude
in the x and the y direction.
If that's the case, then you
have a situation which not only
the direction is changing,
but also the amplitude
is changing as a
function of time.
And that we call it
elliptically polarized.
So that's actually the
three situations we learned.
And also we learned about
how to make polarized light
during the class.
So usually, the light
source we are talking about,
or even present in this
room, like the light
from the light bulb,
et cetera, those
are unpolarized light, right?
So that means you have a lot
of electromagnetic wave emitted
from the light with different
initial time, emission time.
And those are in slightly
different angular frequency,
slightly different
pointing direction.
So you can have all kinds
of different emissions.
And the sum of all
those emissions
is unpolarized light,
which is actually
the light source I have here.
And you can use
so-called polarizer.
So the polarizer can actually
kill one of the direction,
and only keep all the
projection to the easy axis.
And in this presentation,
the easy axis
is in the x direction.
And you can see that if you
start with unpolarized light,
and basically, you have that
pass through a polarizer,
then the resulting
electric field
will be pointing toward
the so-called easy axis.
So the easier axis
to pass, right?
So therefore, all the
electric field perpendicular
to the easy axis is illuminated.
And what is left over
is the electric field,
which is actually
parallel to the easy axis.
And of course, you can
rotate this polarizer
and you would see
that, OK, if you
have a linearly polarized wave
passing through polarizer,
because easy axis
is actually now
in line with the polarization,
what is going to happen
is, as I said, still only the
component which is actually
parallel to the easy
axis will passed through.
And the resulting
electric field will still
be pointing to the
direction of the easy axis.
So that's actually what
we have learned last time.
OK, so that means we
know how to generate
linearly polarized wave, right?
Because you just
need a polarizer
and put it in front
of your light source,
then you produce a
linearly polarized save.
But we didn't talk about
how to produce a circularly
polarized wave, right?
OK, so that is actually
the topic which
I would like to talk about.
So let's take a look
at the diagram here.
So assuming that I have
a single layer of sheet,
which I call wave plate.
This is actually the zoom in
and zoom in of that sheet.
And the interesting property
of this wave plate sheet
is that the refraction
index in the x direction
and the refraction
index for the linearly
polarized wave in the y
direction, they are different.
That can happen, right?
Because when we were
discussing two-dimensional and
three-dimensional waves,
the dispersion relation
can be dependent on
the k vector, right?
So that should not
surprise you by now.
And it depends on the
structure of the material you
use to make this wave plate.
So therefore, you can
have different velocity
when you have an incident where
pointing in the x direction,
and compared to
an incident where
pointing in the y direction.
So in short, we can
actually summarize
this kind of information,
the dispersion relation,
into two components.
One is the velocity, the phase
velocity in the x direction,
which is denoted as nx.
Just a reminder, the
speed of the light
will be equal to c
divided by nx, right?
So larger n means smaller
speed of light in material.
And if that happens, if nx
is different from ny, what
is going to happen is that if
you have an incident wave, when
it passes through this wave
plate, what is going to happen
is that the x component,
the delay in phase
in the x component, would
be different from the delay
in phase in the y component.
And that is, essentially,
how we can actually
make use of that to
create elliptically
polarized wave or circularly
polarized wave, OK?
So let's take a look at
this example together.
So suppose I have incident light
with angular frequency omega,
OK?
Since I give you already the
omega, what I really need
is the speed of light, then
I can calculate the resulting
wave number and wave lengths.
So this is actually the
incident wave angular frequency.
And the lens of the-- or say
the thickness of the wave plate
is called little l.
And we can actually
check immediately
what would be the
corresponding wave
number in the median for
the linearly polarized wave
in the x direction and linearly
polarized wave in the y
direction.
So we can actually
calculate Kx will
be equal to nx over c omega,
because this is actually
just omega divided
by v, which is
the phase velocity in the median
for waves in the x direction.
And that would be equal
to 2 pi over lambda x.
Similarly, you can
also conclude that Ky
can be written as ny
divided by c times omega,
which is 2 pi over lambda u.
Kx and Ky are the
wave numbers inside
for the progressing harmonic
waves inside the median, OK?
One is in the x direction.
The other one's in
the y direction.
So if we keep those in
mind, you will see that,
huh, if I have different nx
and ny, when the same frequency
light goes through this
median, its x component
will travel through
different amount of period,
where is a different
amount of phase difference.
Compared to the
light polarized--
compared to the component
in the y direction,
as you can see from
this demonstration.
Therefore, we can
actually conclude
that there must be
a phase difference
between the x component
and y component.
And we can calculate that--
this is actually delta
phi, the phase difference
between the x direction and y
direction will be equal to 2 pi
times l divided by lambda x.
So basically, it's the
number of waves times 2 pi.
l over lambda x is
number of periods past.
And the times 2 pi
translates that to phase.
And we are taking the
difference between the x
and the y direction.
And we can conclude that based
on what we have written here.
As you see that this
is just nx minus ny
divided by c times
omega times l, OK?
So this is actually how
the wave plate works.
Suppose I have a
linearly polarizer
wave coming into this plate.
And the direction
of the polarization
is not in the x
direction or y direction.
So they are positioned--
they are components in the
x direction and y direction.
For example, I can have an
incoming polarizer like this.
And this is actually
the x direction.
This is actually
the y direction.
And I can now decompose this
kind of linearly polarized wave
into two components.
And after this wave passes
through the wave plate,
x component will be--
the phase difference
between x and y
will be increased by delta phi.
So if originally there
were no phase difference
because this is actually
a linearly polarized wave,
and after it passes
through the wave plate,
it will be increased.
And then the phase
difference between x and y
will be delta phi.
All right, so that's
really nice tour.
And the so-called
quarter wave plate
is a device which we
intentionally set the delta phi
to be pi over 2.
Why is that interesting?
That is because
initially you have
Ex equal to E0 cosine
omega t minus Kz,
and this is actually
the y component.
If initially you have this
kind of incident wave,
now it corresponds
to a polarization
which is actually 45 degree
with respect to the x-axis.
So this is actually the x-axis.
And this is actually the y-axis.
When I have this kind of
linearly polarized wave pass
through the quarter wave
plate, what is going to happen?
What is going to happen is
that one of the components
will be delayed by
delta phi or pi over 2.
That will make you a
circularly polarized wave.
Because that will
become sine and cosine.
Therefore, if you plot the
locus of the electric field
in two-dimensional xy plane,
you will see a circle.
So that is actually
why we want are
interested in a special
setup which delta phi is
equal to pi over 2, OK?
So let me go through
a few examples
so that actually you get some
feelings about what is actually
a quarter wave plate.
Usually, instead of drawing
this complicated diagram,
we actually simplify
the presentation
into a diagram like this.
So basically, you
have a fast axis,
which is the axis with
smaller phase shift.
And you have slow axis, which
is actually the axis with larger
phase shift.
So basically, we just reduce
the whole complicated setup
into a simple diagram like that.
So suppose I have an incident
wave which is actually linearly
polarized in this direction.
In this direction, which
I can call it x direction.
And this is actually
y direction.
And I have that pass through
a quarter wave plate,
where the fast axis
is in the x direction,
and there's a slow axis
in the y direction.
Can somebody tell me, what would
be the resulting polarization
after this electromagnetic wave
passes through this quarter
wave plate?
Somebody want to try it?
Yes.
STUDENT: It would be
polarized in the y direction.
PROFESSOR: Polarized in what?
STUDENT: In the y direction.
PROFESSOR: No.
Basically-- OK, maybe I
didn't explain that clearly.
So initially, in this example,
all the electric field
is in the x direction.
Therefore, in the y direction,
there's nothing there.
So that's actually a
linearly polarized wave.
The direction in actually
in the x direction.
And this quarter
wave plate is going
to slow down the y component
by a phase of pi over 2.
So what would be the
resulting polarization?
Yes.
STUDENT: Very similar
to [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
So because we are dividing
something which is zero.
But zero is zero.
So zero is zero is zero, right?
So therefore, what you
are going to get is this.
It's still a linearly
polarized wave, right?
OK, doesn't surprise you after
I explain to you more clearly.
And then you can see
that if you have this--
OK, now I change the situation.
So this is the x direction.
This is the y direction.
And I have something
which is 45 degrees.
And I have that pass
through the same setup.
Slow axis is in the y
direction and the fast axis
is in the x direction.
What will we get?
What kind of polarized
light will we
get after it passed through
this quarter wave plate?
Somebody can help me?
STUDENT: Circular.
PROFESSOR: Circular, yes.
Thank you very much.
So that's actually
exactly what I was
talking about in the beginning.
The y component will be
delayed by pi over 2.
Therefore, it would become
a circularly polarized wave.
How about I change
this to 30 degrees?
What is going to happen?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it will be
elliptically polarized, right?
Because now the projection
to a different component
is different.
So therefore, it would be
elliptically polarized wave.
Very good.
It seems to me that
most of you actually
understand what we are doing.
And now it's time to do some
experiment to actually show you
what we have done.
Yes.
STUDENT: It's a little
more complicated
than that because the
slope the refraction
is [INAUDIBLE] be much, much
slower than the fast axis.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
You are absolutely right.
So it depends on the
delta phi, right?
So if delta phi
is not pi over 2,
then it can be
elliptically polarized.
And in this setup, I say that
this is actually a quarter wave
plate, therefore,
the delay is always
delta phi equal to pi over 2.
Yeah.
So then-- thank you for that.
This is what we
have been discussing
is always quarter wave plate.
Therefore, the delta phi
between the slow and fast axis
is always pi over 2, OK?
So that everybody
is on the same page.
Yes.
STUDENT: How can
you have a material
that has a different refraction
index for different directions?
PROFESSOR: For example, we
were talking about materials--
or say the two-dimensional
discrete case, right?
So we can have
little mass arranged
in the x and y direction.
But the space between mass in
the x direction and y direction
are different, then you
have a dispersion relation
which is actually
different for the harmonic
wave in the x direction
compared to y direction.
And that's just
some random example.
And that can be
achieved by engineering
the material we will use
for the wave plate, OK?
Good question.
All right, so we will
go ahead and I'll
show you some demonstration.
We prepare.
The first thing I have to
do is to turn off the light
to have some more excitement.
I cannot even see where
is my experiment now.
Oh, right here, yeah.
OK, woo.
OK, so look at
what we have here.
This is a projector.
So what is the
polarization of that light?
STUDENT: Unpolarized.
PROFESSOR: Unpolarized.
Yeah, very good.
OK, I'm very happy to hear that.
All right, so now I have the
polarizer and I put it on it.
What is the polarization
of this light?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I couldn't hear you.
STUDENT: It's linear.
PROFESSOR: Linear, yeah.
Linearly of-- don't be afraid.
OK, you can say that.
No, this is not linear.
The edge is not linear, right?
But it's OK.
I'm talking about everything
inside of this material.
Very good.
So now what I'm going to
do is to put two polarizers
on top of each other.
And of course, I can rotate such
that the polarizer, the easy
axis is perpendicular
to each other, OK?
So you see that ha, I almost
black most of that light.
So the first thing
which I have been doing
is that I first turn this
unpolarized light polarized.
And it's actually
oscillating in one direction.
And I block it again
with the second one.
And then you see
that it's black.
It's consistent
with what we expect.
So we are happy.
We are not happy?
No?
Yes, we are happy.
All right, so remember the
discussion we had before.
So what I could do is to add a
third one, a third polarizer.
So I can have the
first polarizer
which actually makes the
direction of the oscillation
in this direction.
Then I put a second
polarizer, where the easy axis
is in this direction.
Then I actually-- I'm going
to extract all the components
which projected to this axis.
Therefore, after passing
the second polarizer,
the oscillation of the wave
will be in this direction.
Therefore, aha, now I put
the third polarizer on,
you can see that in the
middle, because it changed
the direction of the
polarization by 45 degrees
already by this
polarizer, therefore
you can see that there's
some residual light survived.
And then you can
actually calculate
what will be the intensity of
the light surviving these three
polarizers.
And you can see
that the ones which
didn't pass the second polarizer
is actually completely blocked
by the two polarizers,
which their easy axes are
perpendicular to each other.
So now, the interesting
thing is that now I
have a quarter wave plate here.
OK, it's here.
Hope you can see it.
And I'm going to insert
this into this experiment
and see what is going to happen.
Look at what we have here.
Oh, this is actually
much brighter, right?
So basically, this water--
this quarter wave plate--
sorry, it's not water--
quarter wave plate, OK?
Quarter wave plate actually
turned the polarized light
into a circularly
polarized light.
And after this circularly
polarized light
continued and passed
through the third polarizer,
you can see that,
huh, the light passed
through this kind
of combination is
a lot more than this experiment
which was three polarizers.
And we can also
calculate what would
be the expected intensity.
And the good news is that we
are not going to calculate that
now, but in your P set.
So you will be able to show
that, indeed, the intensity you
expect with quarter wave plate
will be higher than why you
expect with three polarizers.
So that's actually
the first experiment
I would like to show you.
The second experiment is
also very interesting.
So I have here--
OK, first I need to see if
I can turn on the light.
I have to turn on this light.
Very good.
So look at this tube.
This tube is made
of water and sugar.
So we all love sugar.
And I love it too much, so I
add too much into this tube.
So it's actually
oversaturated sugar water.
And so there is sugar inside
and there are some animal
or whatever living inside.
But we don't care.
We are not studying biology.
But what is actually
interesting is that, OK, now I
have a light source from
the lamp inside emitting
what kind of polarized light?
Unpolarized light, right?
And I have that pass through
a polarizer, which is here.
There's a polarizer here.
And therefore,
what I want to say
is that the incident light
into this tube is polarized.
That's the first
thing I want to say.
The second thing I want
to say is that, OK,
a linearly polarized light,
due to superposition principle,
actually you can
decompose that into two
circularly polarized light.
Both of them are
actually rotating
in different directions.
You can actually
work on the mass
and you will see that,
ha, indeed, it works.
So our linearly polarized
light you can always rewrite it
as a superposition
of two circularly
polarized light, but rotating
in different directions.
The interesting
thing is the material
which we use in this
demonstration is oversaturated
sugar.
And we know that the molecule
for the sugar and those kind
of material is asymmetric
under mirror transformation.
It's asymmetric.
It's a chiral material.
OK, chiral is actually
just some name,
but it doesn't mean
anything to you.
But what is actually interesting
is that this material
is asymmetric.
If you have a mirror
and this material
is looking at the mirror, in
the other side of the mirror,
it looks different.
It's like your hand, right?
So in a mirror, it's asymmetric.
So what is interesting is that
due to this kind of structure
in the material that the
light passed through,
the circularly polarized light,
counterclockwise polarized
light, will have
different refractive index
compared to clockwise.
Clockwise and
counterclockwise light
will have different
refractive index.
Therefore, you see that now you
can see some kind of rotation
or some kind of change
in the polarization
as a function of distance
the light travels through.
So basically, this
material would
rotate the linearly
polarized light,
because the refractive
index for the clockwise and
counterclockwise are different.
So if you accept
that, I would like
to add another complication.
In addition to that,
the refractive index
also depends on the frequency
of the incident light.
Therefore, you will have
different amount of rotation
for different color.
So therefore, you
can see that once I
have incident light which
is linearly polarized,
all the colors are lined up.
You can see that here.
What is the color here?
It's kind of bluish or
white, essentially, right?
But if you move slightly more,
then it becomes pretty blue.
And then if you move more,
because of the dependence
of the refractive index as
a function of wavelength,
therefore, you can see that
this whole thing is actually
changing color.
And in the end, I have
another polarizer which
filter one of the directions.
And I can change the
direction, and you
will see that I can filter
out different colors.
Which color do you like?
Now it's red.
And of course, I can
rotate this polarizer,
and I am sampling
different color.
Because at the time
different color of light
passes through
this material, they
are rotated by different
amount of degree.
Therefore, I can filter
out and create all kinds
of different color on the wall.
The other thing which is
interesting which I can do
is that I can now change that
direction of the incident
light, or the direction of the
polarization of the incident
light, by rotating this one.
You can see that the whole tube
is changing color, like why you
see in the barber shop, right?
OK, so maybe this is a fancy
way to make that kind of tube.
No?
A physics barber shop.
Maybe we should do that.
OK, so I hope you enjoyed
this demonstration.
And we will take a five minute
break to take questions.
And the next topic we
are going to talk about
is how do we actually create
electromagnetic wave at all.
So let's come back in 15.
OK, so I hope you can hear me.
All right, so welcome
back from the break.
So we are going to talk about
the second topic we would like
to cover in the lecture today.
The question we are asking
is, how do we actually
create electromagnetic waves
and so-called radiation?
So this is actually a picture
from Hubble telescope.
And you can see that
light can travel
through billions, or tens
of billions, of light years
and arrive at Earth.
And you can actually
measure them
and see you what is actually
going on in the past.
And that means if
you have a source
and you have some
kind of radiation,
and this source is going to emit
energy towards somewhere, which
is actually really, really
far away toward the edge
of the universe.
So that is actually what we
call electromagnetic wave
and radiation.
But the what is actually
requirement for that to happen?
What is the requirement
for us to be
able to see the stars
which are so far away?
That's the question.
So let me actually make
a simple argument here.
Suppose I have some
kind of a light source.
It's a source in the center.
And we have learned about
pointing vector, right?
So what this actually
pointing vector?
It's not really the
pointing vector, right?
So it's rate of energy
transfer per unit area.
So it's kind of
pointing, but it's
pointing to the direction
of the energy transfer.
So this is a vector.
And it's actually highly
related to the direction
of the electric field
and the magnetic field.
And now, if I--
since this is essentially
the energy transfer per area,
I can now capture the average
pointing vector times area.
And what is going to happen is
that if I do this calculation
at this surface--
this is actually a sphere
which is covering this source.
I can do this at
sphere number 1.
And I can actually also do
that in the sphere number 2.
Since there are absolutely
no other source--
I'm assuming that there's
only one source here.
There's only one light
source in the universe,
which is kind of lonely.
Apparently it's not my universe,
but somebody else's problem.
And then I will conclude that
since there's nothing outside,
I will conclude that S
times A, if I evaluate that
in the first surface,
will be equal to S
times A in the second surface.
That's equal to power, OK?
So that should not
surprise anybody.
So that means the
pointing vector
will be proportional to 1/A,
which is the surface area.
And that means, based on
simple mathematics, that
would be proportional
to 1 over r
squared for this constant
power transfer to happen.
So this means that
there's a source.
And if I integrate all
the energy transfer
from some kind of
surface, it's going
to be a constant, no matter
what surface you are choosing.
So that means if I look
at the structure of the S
vector, the pointing
vector, we can
conclude that at least
the electric field
and magnetic field has to
be proportional to 1/r,
which is the distance with
respect to the source.
Otherwise, it's going to be
decaying faster, or reducing
faster than 1/r, then the
total power will approach zero
when you increase r enough.
Then that means if
you have that happen,
you will not see anything
if you are far enough.
So if that's
actually the case, we
can now come back and
discuss two situations which
we are very familiar with.
For example, you
can say, how about I
have a stationary charge?
So I can have a
stationary charge
and see what will happen.
And apparently, if
I have a charge here
without actually moving
it, it's going to emit--
basically, it is going to have
an electric field around this.
But electric field, based on
what we learned from 8.02,
is going to be 2 divided by 4
pi epsilon zero r squared r hat.
It's going to be proportional
to 1 over r squared.
It's already not very good news,
because it's proportional to 1
over r squared.
And it's hitted by this.
The magnetic field is zero.
If I have something
times zero it's zero.
Then there will be
no energy transfer
if you have a stationary
charge just sitting there.
So apparently, this
is not a good way
to create electromagnetic
wave, based on our argument.
The pointing vector is
actually equal to zero.
So now you can say, OK,
this is actually too boring,
so let's introduce
some excitement.
How about we make this charge
moving at a constant speed?
What we can do is like this.
Basically, if you have a
positively charged particle,
you can actually make it
move at a constant speed,
velocity equal to v. And what
you are going to see is that,
oh, indeed, there will be some
changes in the electric field
and the magnetic field.
And I'm not going to go
through the calculation
of this kind of situation.
And I will leave
that as an exercise.
But I would like to tell you
what would be the conclusion.
So if you have a single
charge, which is essentially
moving at a constant speed,
and what is going to happen
is that the electric field
density, or the field line
density will change.
And you will be more
concentrated in the direction,
which is essentially
perpendicular to the direction
of the motion of this charge.
And we can actually
calculate what
would be the electric field.
The electric field will be equal
to q divided by 4 pi epsilon0 r
squared, 1 minus beta squared.
I will define bet in a moment.
1 minus beta
squared sine squared
theta 3/2 in the r direction.
And where the beta is actually
defined as u/c, which is u
is actually the velocity
of this little charge.
And of course, you
can also calculate
what would be the
corresponding B, right?
The magnetic field will be
actually equal to u plus E
divided by c squared.
And that is actually
proportional to 1
over r squared.
As you can see from
here, the bad news
is that, OK, you indeed now
have both electric field
and the magnetic field.
There is some improvement.
But the problem is
that the reduction
of the electric field
and the magnetic field
is a function of distance.
It's too large.
Both of them are proportional
to 1 over r squared,
proportional to
1 over r squared.
Therefore, the magnitude
of S will be proportional 1
over r to the fourth.
So if you are far
enough, you can
conclude that the total
power will approach zero,
even if you integrate
over the whole surface
surrounding this moving charge.
So apparently, that's
actually not the solution
we are seeking.
Therefore, we have
to do something
more aggressive to
accelerate the charge.
So you can now have a charge
moving at a constant speed.
We see that it
didn't do anything.
Therefore, we have to
make the velocity increase
and see what'll happen.
So what I am going to do
now requires concentration.
So I will hope that
you don't take notes.
Just follow me so that you
get what I am trying to argue.
And of course, if you are
really good in mathematics,
you can actually also go
through page 356 to 360
in George's book.
There are some really
mathematical deviations
of the radiation from
an accelerated charge.
So let's try to see how
can we actually understand
an accelerated charge
and what is actually
the associated
electromagnetic field.
So my goal is to have
some kind of acceleration.
So I would like to
set up the stage.
So let's take a look
at the slide here.
At t equal to zero,
time equal to zero,
before I introduce
any excitement,
I have a charged particle
initially at rest.
And it's sitting there.
What I'm going to do is that at
some point, at t equal to zero,
I try to accelerate this charge
until t equal to delta t.
The original position of that
charged particle is at a.
And I try to accelerate this
charge by acceleration a.
And that only happened in a
very small amount of time,
which is delta t.
So what is going to
happen is that this charge
will get accelerated.
And you can see that the
velocity of the charge--
you can see velocity as
a function of time here--
is increasing linearly in
this period, and reaching
maxima, which is a delta t.
So after that, I stop
the acceleration.
So originally, the
charge is at rest.
Then I accelerate it
for some period of time.
And I stop the acceleration at
A prime, or t equal to delta t.
And what is going to happen
afterwards to the charge?
Everybody is following?
You will be moving
at constant velocity.
Very good.
So that's actually
what you see here.
And the wave can actually--
this information can propagate
as a function of time.
So that's actually
the whole setup,
which I would like to discuss.
Before that, I would like
to bring your attention
to the graph I was
trying to draw here.
So you can see that
originally there
is a line which is pointing
up, like 45 degree with respect
to this charge.
So that's one of the field
lines I was drawing here.
That's actually the
electric field line.
And as you can see that as
I manipulate this charged
particle, this is a sphere--
or a circle I should--
on this slide, which
is actually telling you
where this information already
propagated in the space.
So for example, if
I am sitting here
in the position of
my little mouse here.
Can you see that?
No, you cannot see it.
If I'm sitting in the upper
right corner of the slide,
and I try to--
then the experiment starts
and I move the charge,
the observer at the upper right
corner would not feel anything.
Because it takes time for the
field, or for the changes,
or for the information to
be sent from the position A
to the observer, which are far
away from the charged particle.
And the surface which--
the surface is actually where
the information has propagated.
So this information that
my charge is accelerated,
this information has
already propagated
to a sphere, which is actually
far away by c times delta t
away from the center,
which is the location
of the charged particle.
And you can see that
as time goes on,
this black circle is actually
becoming larger and larger,
which contains the
information that,
OK, I accelerated the charge.
This is actually where you can
see that out of this circle
is as if the charge
is stationary.
So you can see the field
line is still linear.
And passing through this
line, or say, this surface,
the information is
already propagated.
If you standing inside this
line, like for example,
next to the question
mark, if you are there,
you feel, aha, now I
observe the acceleration
to the charged particle.
Finally, if I go toward the
charged particle even more,
and I will see, aha, if I am
now inside the green circle,
I know that this
charged particle already
stopped the acceleration.
It's now moving
at constant speed.
So that's the meaning of
these two little circles.
And now I am looking at
the situation at time
equal to t where the
charge is at position B.
And I should see something
really interesting.
As I mentioned before, if you
have a constantly propagating
charge, the field
line is actually still
a straight line, actually,
right there in the equation.
If you have a
stationary charge, it's
also a linear straight line.
And you can see that you
have two straight lines,
but in between, there's a kink
which connects these two lines.
So between these two
lines, basically this
is actually what we have here.
So we have the
original particle.
And this is actually where
the particle have the field
line as a moving charge.
And there's another
surface, which
actually out of
the surface, it's
like there is no
acceleration at all.
The charge is still
stationary at A.
You can see that these two
field lines are linear,
and also essentially in
the radial direction.
But the excitement is that
since the field line has
to be continuous, the excitement
is that I have successfully
created a kink, which
is actually propagating
in the radial direction.
And this kink is going to be our
electromagnetic wave because it
has a component which is
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation.
Just a reminder,
what is actually
an electromagnetic
field looks like, it
looks like this, right?
So basically, you have
the electric field
oscillating up and down
in one of the directions,
the polarization--
linearly polarized
electromagnetic wave.
And the whole wave is
actually propagating
toward the right-hand
side of the board.
And the electric field is in
the perpendicular direction
of the direction of propagation.
And this kink is actually
what we are looking for, OK?
And that really becomes
the electromagnetic wave
right there from
the point source.
Any questions so far?
Everybody's following?
OK, so now, that's good.
We have managed to
create this situation.
And I would like
to be more concrete
about several settings.
The first one is actually we
have a constant acceleration a,
and this delta t
is really small.
Very small delta t,
very small acceleration.
Therefore, I would assume
that u defined as delta t,
the resulting velocity
is much, much smaller
than the speed of light.
So that's actually the setup
which I would like to use.
Then the question now
is, how do we actually
evaluate what will
be the magnitude
of this so-called
kink electric field?
So for this, it's
actually also pretty easy.
So now I would like to copy the
geometry which I have there.
I am trying to draw a copy
of that to my board here.
So basically, originally the
charge is stationary at A.
And it's emitting an electric
field, which is actually only
in the radial direction.
And it got accelerated
by a really small time.
I'm exaggerating
in that figure, OK?
So it got accelerated a
really small amount of time.
And after that, it
reached a prime,
which is the exaggerated version
is actually probably there.
And A and A prime is, in fact,
very, very close to each other,
because this is actually just
a very, very small delta t.
I can have delta t goes to zero.
Then A and A prime would
be very, very similar.
And now I let the time
go on, and now this
charged particle is now at
point B. It's moved to point B.
And I can connect
B to A and A prime.
And I can actually
conclude that, OK,
since the resulting velocity
of the charged particle
up to a prime is actually equal
to u, defined as a times delta
t, and we are now
at time equal to t.
Therefore, the
distance these charged
particles pass through,
or travel through,
is actually u times t.
Doesn't surprise you, right?
So that's velocity times t.
And also, we can actually
calculate this lens.
This lens is actually--
I call it this
point D here, which
is the intersection
between the second surface
and the original field line.
And I call this one E, which is
the intersection of the field
line from the moving charge
and the second surface.
And finally, I also
have the intersection,
which I call it F,
which is actually
where the field line and
the surface actually join,
which is actually the
information about the charge
has moved is actually
the surface, which
within that surface, people
know the charge is actually
already moved.
So once I have all these, I can
now evaluate what will be at D
and F. D and F are actually
pretty straightforward as well,
because all those surfaces are
traveling at the speed of what?
Light, right.
So what is actually the delta
t between these two surfaces?
It's delta t, right?
Because I actually stopped
the acceleration at delta t,
therefore, the distance
between D point and F
is actually just
c times delta t.
And of course, now I have this.
I can connect E and D. And
roughly, because a and a prime
are very, very
close to each other,
and also t is very large,
therefore the BE, this line,
is roughly parallel
to these AF line.
So these two lines are actually
roughly parallel to each other.
Therefore, I can
now evaluate what
will be this line, D and E--
what would be the size of
the distance between D and E.
And that can be evaluated.
And it's actually just u
perpendicular times t--
perpendicular to the
direction of the field.
And I can copy that here.
The distance between D and E is
just u perpendicular times t.
And of course, I can approximate
that is actually just a line.
And I have a theta angle
which is actually DEF.
So now I can actually try
to use this information,
this geometrical
argument information,
to figure out what will be
the electric field, this kink.
So now I can have the electric
field, the same triangle here,
this is angle theta.
And this is the electric
field parallel to the AF line.
And I can have
also E perp, which
is actually the perpendicular
to AF, this line.
And the kink, E
kink, is actually
what we would like to
figure out as well.
And basically, this E kink is
what we want to figure out.
And the E has the
following two components.
One is the E parallel.
The other one is
the E perp, which
is the perpendicular and the
parallel components to the AF
line.
And we can already make use
of the similarity of these two
triangles, right?
Basically, this field line
is actually pure geometrical,
therefore, I know
what is actually
theta from this
geometrical argument.
So what is actually
theta, basically, you
can get that from the
information of c delta t.
And then u perp times t.
So therefore, I can
conclude that the magnitude
of E perp divided by
magnitude of E parallel
will be equal to u perp
t divided by c delta t.
And this E kink is like this.
It actually has a direction.
However, you can see
that, wait a second,
you have this ratio, right?
But the E kink is actually
pointing to this direction.
And this ut is pointing
up to upward direction.
Therefore, if you
take this ratio,
the E kink will be pointing
to the upper left direction.
Therefore, you really need
a minus sign here, right?
Therefore, the E perp
would be pointing downward.
Therefore, that's actually how
you get this minus sign there.
From this pure
geometrical argument,
you can actually
conclude what would
be the ratio between E perp
and the E parallel, which
is actually equal to that.
And I can write it
down explicitly.
Basically, that's going to
be equal to a delta t times
t divided by c delta t.
Remember, u is equal
to a times delta t.
Therefore, I can
now cancel delta t.
Then basically, what I get is
minus a perp t divided by c.
And now this is
actually equal to minus
a perp r divided
by c squared, where
r is actually just c times t.
r is actually the distance
between the position
you are evaluating this field
and the origin, which is A, OK?
So you can now
conclude that-- based
on this geometrical
argument, you
can conclude that E
perp is highly related
to the E parallel.
The E perp is equal to
minus a perp r divided
by c squared E parallel.
Any questions so far?
Yes.
STUDENT: How'd you
get r real quick?
PROFESSOR: R is actually--
yeah, so r is actually
just c times t.
So it's the whole
distance is the r.
Cool.
All right, so you can see that
right now all of those things
are purely geometrical, right?
So this is really no magic.
And no even integration.
So now we are going to
do some integration.
So now we are almost there.
I would like to figure out
what would be the E kink.
And I am especially
interested in E perp,
because E perp is
the direction which
is actually perpendicular to
the direction of propagation.
It's really cool.
So that's actually
related to the magnitude
of the electromagnetic
field radiating.
So I would like to
know E perp, but I
don't know what is E parallel.
So what we could do is to use
Gauss' law in this example.
So now what I could
do is that I can
draw a pillbox,
which is actually
through the surface number 1.
This is actually
surface number 1.
What I could do is I can draw
a pillbox which is actually
passing through the
surface number 1.
Out of surface number 1, we
know the physics very well,
which is actually
the electric field
of a single stationary charge.
So therefore, I know what is
actually the electric field
outside.
Which is actually
pointing outward
in the radial direction.
And the E parallel is actually
what we are stuck with.
So we don't know
what is actually
the magnitude of E parallel.
That's the electric field
inside the surface number 1.
Makes sense?
So now we also
have the component
which is actually
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation.
So this is actually the
contribution of the E perp
and the contribution of E perp,
which they go from the side
to the site.
Go in from the side, go out
from the side of this pillbox.
So I can now
immediately conclude
that the total contribution
of this surface integral
will be equal to 0,
because of Gauss' law.
There's no charge in my pillbox.
Therefore, all those
things should cancel.
Apparently, these will
cancel, because side
in, side out, the same
magnitude, which is E perp.
Therefore, that
cancel is trivial.
And the interesting
thing is that we can also
figure out that e parallel
will have to be equal to E out.
So that the sum of all the
integral will be equal to 0,
because of Gauss' law.
That's actually a very
big amount of information,
because I know how
to write down E out.
So E parallel will
be equal to E out.
We learned from 8.02 this
is actually just q divided
by 4 pi epsilon0 r squared.
Does that surprise you?
Should not, right, because
out of the surface,
people think nothing
actually really
happened to the
charged particle.
So it's actually still
stationary sitting there.
So therefore, I have the
information of E parallel,
therefore, I can now conclude
what would be the E perp.
Now, E perp will be equal to
minus q a perp divided by 4 pi
epsilon0 c squared r,
because this is actually
just a perp minus
a perp r divided
by c squared times E parallel.
Look at what we have achieved.
Look at this.
This is actually
proportional to what?
1/r, right?
So that means the decaying
speed of this E perp
is really slow compared
to the electric field
from a stationary charge.
So that's actually
very encouraging.
And of course, you
can also write down
what will be the
resulting magnetic field.
And it's going to be
also proportional to 1/r.
So what we can
actually conclude is
that the E rad is a function
of direction of the--
evaluating this E
radiated electric field is
a function of t.
And we can actually--
based on this exercise,
this will be minus q.
a is a vector, but
now I only take
the perpendicular direction.
And this thing is
actually evaluated
at t minus r over c divided
by 4 pi epsilon0 c squared r.
Let's take a look
at this formula
closely together, since we
have spent a lot of time
trying to get this result.
So look at this structure.
So basically, the
radiated energy
has a minus sign in
front of q and a perp,
because the E kink
is actually pointing
in the opposite
direction compared
to the directional acceleration,
as you can see from here.
The E kink and the
E perpendicular
is pointing to the opposite
direction of the acceleration.
Therefore, we have
this minus sign there.
And only the perpendicular
direction motion, acceleration,
works.
And there's this little
component here, t minus r/c.
This is actually--
now multiplying
this factor is evaluated at
the t equal to t minus r/c.
It's evaluated at that time.
So this is actually
evaluated at retarded time.
So that means I am really slow.
I need to wait for
the information
to arrive my detector so that
I know there are acceleration
happening.
Finally, I can now
also conclude what
will be the magnetic field.
The magnetic field
rad, as I mentioned,
would be proportional to 1/r.
And of course, I also give
you the explicit formula
in the lecture notes.
And now we can actually conclude
that s will be proportional
to 1 over r squared.
So that means I
can now send energy
to the edge of the universe,
because of all this hard work
we have been doing here.
Any questions?
All right, before the
end of the lecture
today, I'm going to show
you an experiment here.
So here I have an
antenna, which you
can have electron
going back and forth,
oscillating harmonically
really, really fast like this.
Therefore, there will
be acceleration, because
of this harmonic oscillation.
And I'm going to
turn off the light.
Also probably hide the image.
OK, this is good.
But I have to be able
to see the button.
Can I see it?
No.
Oh, I'm in trouble.
Ah, here.
OK, here I have a receiver.
It's also a metal rod.
And I have a light
bulb in between,
which is actually trying to
receive the information from--
or say that it receives the
electromagnetic wave emitted
from that source.
Which you have electrons
going back and forth
in that direction.
So now, first, I
am trying to align
my setup in this direction
so that it's really--
what would be the polarization
of an electromagnetic wave?
The polarization is going to
be in a horizontal direction.
Yes, very good.
Therefore, if I have
this set up like this,
it's actually perpendicular
to the direction
of the polarization,
therefore, I see nothing here,
It is also possible that the
light bulb is actually broken,
but let's see.
So now what I'm going to do
is to change the direction.
You see that?
I am moving also closer
really carefully.
Now you can see what happened.
You can see that now I receive
the signal from this machine.
The emitted light is
actually polarized
in the horizontal direction.
And now I have also the
electron going back and forth,
and that actually can
light up the light bulb.
Now, if I change
the direction, you
can see that this
is actually gone.
And I can do this again.
And I can go farther
away from the source.
You can see that now the light
is actually disappearing.
Why?
That is because you
get the 1/r term.
Therefore, it's
actually disappearing.
And if I move closer to the
source, it's reappearing.
So now I need an assistant
to hold this thing for me.
Who can volunteer?
And I would like to rotate that.
I can actually also
rotate my setup.
Can you help?
Yes.
OK, be careful.
And I hope you can survive this.
So now what am I going to do--
OK, so stay there.
And what I'm going to do is
I can rotate the whole setup,
the same concept.
If I rotate the setup, I have
to be careful so that I am not
touching this more.
I want to survive.
And you can see now
what is actually
the direction of the emission.
It's actually in this
direction, right?
The direction of
the polarization
is in the back and
forth direction.
And you see that that the light
bulb is actually turned off.
And now I can turn it back on.
And you see that
it's still there.
OK, thank you very much.
You survived.
Not everybody actually
survives this.
[LAUGHTER]
So you can see it now I can
move really close to this thing.
And what is going to happen?
The amount of energy
will be too high,
and probably this light
bulb will explode or broken.
Do you want to see that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, my god.
Let's see.
Ooh, [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
OK, very good.
So now this experiment is dead.
And then we can--
it's a very good time
to close the lecture today.
And thank you very much for
attending the lecture today.
And I hope now you understand
how we actually create light.
And enjoy the
homework, because you
will be able to figure out
why the quarter wave plate
combination will give you
a higher light intensity.
OK, so if you have
any questions,
I will be here and
just standing up here.
OK, hello everybody.
Today I'm going to show you a
demonstration, which actually
demonstrates the effect of
polarizer and quarter wave
plate.
Here is the setup.
I have a projector here, which
emits our polarizer light.
And if I put a sheet of
polarizer on top of it
with easy axis in the
vertical direction,
like what my finger--
in the direction oscillation
along the direction
of my finger, then
basically, you
will see that the intensity
of the light is reduced.
Because for the
unpolarized light,
light component
which is actually
oscillating along the easy axis
can pass through the polarizer,
but the component
which is actually
oscillating perpendicular
to the easy axis, like this,
is not going to
pass the polarizer.
Therefore, a large fraction
of unpolarized light
is actually filtered out,
and you will see a reduction
in the intensity on the screen.
So what I'm going to do now
is to place another polarizer
on top of the first one.
So now we have two sheets.
And you can see that after
adding the second sheet,
you see some change
in the intensity.
But if I rotate this
sheet so that now
the easy axis of the
first and the second sheet
are perpendicular to each
other, you can see on the screen
that all the light which are
emitted from the projector
is actually filtered out.
Why is that?
That is because now the first
sheet actually filters out
all that light which is actually
oscillating in the direction
perpendicular to the easy axis.
If I actually introduce another
filter which has easy axis
now perpendicular to the
one from the first sheet,
then I'm going to filter
out both directions.
Therefore, all the
light are filtered out
due to this putting
perpendicular setup.
Now, if I introduce
a third sheet,
insert that between the
two existing sheets,
but now I am trying
to actually insert
that such that the
direction of the easy axis
is actually 45
degrees with respect
to the easy axis
of the first sheet.
According to our calculation in
class, also in your homework,
you should see some light which
will pass through this setup.
And let's take a look at
the experimental result.
You can see that, indeed,
after you insert a third sheet,
you see that now the
easy axis is actually
45 degrees with respect
to the first sheet.
And you do see the intensity
of the light becomes larger,
or you see a brighter
light output passing
through these three polarizers.
And if I rotate it
so that actually
the easy axis of the second
sheet is actually changing,
you can see that
it reached maxima
at roughly 45 degrees,
which is actually
consistent with what we
predicted from your homework.
And then the other thing which
you predicted from the homework
is that if we insert a quarter
wave plate between these two
sheets, you are going to
see a brighter light passing
through this setup.
So let's actually
take a look at what
will happen by inserting
the quarter wave
plate between these two sheets.
And this is actually
the result. You
can see that, indeed,
the intensity is higher
compared to the three
polarizer experiment.
And also, the intensity
actually reached maxima
when the fast axis
of the polarizer
is 45 degrees with
respect to the easy axis,
as we predicted
from your homework.
And we can actually put both
experimental results side
by side.
Indeed, the results from the--
so now I am inserting
the polarizer also
between the two sheets.
And you can see that,
indeed, the light passing
through three
polarizers, the intensity
is actually lower than two
polarizers and the one quarter
wave plate setup.
Hello, everybody.
So today, we are going to
show you a demonstration
of dipole radiation.
Here is the setup.
So we have a radiator
here with two antenna.
And when I turn it down,
there will be current
going back and forth
through these two antenna.
And therefore,
this setup is going
to emit polarized
electromagnetic wave.
And we are able to detect
those electromagnetic waves
by using a detector here, which
consists of two antenna and one
light bulb here.
When there are current
on this antenna,
you will see the light
emitting from the light bulb.
And the intensity
of the light bulb
actually can help
us to understand
the structure of the radiation
from the dipole radiator.
So what I am going to do now
is to turn this setup on.
You can see now, the setup
is on and the light is on.
And there will be current
going back and forth
through these two antenna.
So since the oscillation
of the charge will
generate electromagnetic wave--
since the direction
of oscillation
is in the horizontal direction,
therefore, the electric field
of the electromagnetic
wave is going
to be in the
horizontal direction.
So this can be actually verified
by using the detector here.
When my detector-- the
direction of the antenna
is actually perpendicular to the
direction of the oscillation,
you basically don't
see any light emitting
from the light bulb.
Now I'm going to
rotate my detector.
You can see that as we actually
rotate so that the antenna is
parallel to the direction
of the oscillation,
then you will see
that, huh, we will
see a large intensity of light
emitted from the light bulb.
But on the other hand, if
we actually rotate such
that the direction
of the antenna
is perpendicular to the
direction of oscillation
of the charges,
then you will not
see any light emitted
from the light bulb.
This can also be demonstrated
from on the other side
of the experiment.
So now, instead of standing
in front of the setup,
I'm going to go to the side
of this dipole radiator.
So here is actually roughly
90 degrees with respect
to where I was standing.
And you can see that
no matter which angle--
no matter which angle of my
detector is in, basically,
you will never see light
emitted from the light bulb.
That is because the
direction of the oscillation
is in this direction.
And according to our
formula, our prediction
is that there will be no
electromagnetic wave traveling
in this direction.
And therefore, no matter
which angle you are actually
trying to detect
the emitted light,
the light bulb will
never light up.
So that's essentially
consistent with our declaration.
The second thing which I would
like to actually show you
is that we can also
detect the nodal point
of the emitted
electromagnetic wave
by moving this detector
around in the classroom.
For example, if now I move
farther away from the dipole,
now I am here and you can
see that the intensity goes
to zero at this point,
because we are actually
in one of the nodes of the
electromagnetic radiation.
And if I now move further
away from the setup,
you can see now the light
is actually emitting again.
And also, the
intensity increases.
And again, if I move farther
and farther away from the setup,
you can see that the light
becomes dimmer and dimmer,
and disappears again.
Here is actually another
node in the classroom.
And also, you can see that
as a function of distance,
the maxima intensity
emitted by the light bulb
is also decreasing because of
the larger and larger distance
with respect to the source.
So this demonstration
actually shows
that we can understand
the dipole radiation.
And the other
experimental results
are consistent with
the calculation
we have done in class.